one of the things that we've been
talking about is how the political
discourse is coarsened under Donald
Trump but the roots of this actually
predate Trump by quite a bit yeah
Trump is the anti intellectual president
he's coalesced one of the least least
educated and most uninformed elements of
the electorate for his benefit but that
was already starting to happen under
george w bush decrying education as
liberal indoctrination has gone back for
a while republicans have known for a
long time that when people learn
critical thinking and epistemology they
are way less likely to vote republicans
so they've rooted out those subjects
from public school curricula in many
states where they've taken control of
the Boards of Education but there is an
element of this that goes beyond simply
anti intellectualism which is that
trolling has become considered
legitimate political discourse yes
xenophobic talking points are considered
political discourse under Trump yes the
stuff that people like ben shapiro and
charlie cork do at college is considered
political discourse now but straight up
trolling is also considered political
discourse now so trolling just so we can
define it trolling is deliberately
posting or saying the most inflammatory
extraneous or off-topic thing that you
can in the discussion so rather than
participating in the discussion in good
faith you're effectively D railing the
conversation sowing discord trying to
cause disagreements or arguments or even
just getting people to give up
participating in the conversation
altogether and there's a really good
piece in Wired by Jonathan Albright who
says trolling is now considered
mainstream political discourse the
Overton Window of acceptable behavior in
political conversations and discourse
has been widened to include as if it
were legitimate over trolling there's a
really good study of social media
messages which finds that over time more
and more the message is posted about
political issues and about candidates
are messages that are sort of a mix of
hate speech harassment amplifying
unproven rumors and conspiracies
spreading fake news swarming and
dogpiling people and just the
attacks character assassinations and
insults the number of comments about
politics that are meant to inspire
action like voting or activism
contacting elected officials those are
diminishing more and more now this is
true on the left and right we don't have
to argue in what proportion the right is
much more a purveyor of fake news much
more a purveyor of conspiracy theories
there's no question about that the
trolling is mixed but we don't have to
debate who does it more because it hurts
the left more that's the reality the
right wins when fewer people vote the
right wins when fewer people are engaged
if more and more of the discussion is
the type that makes people like voting
is pointless like their voices are
relevant that they become frustrated and
they bail out the right wins when the
algorithms and the filter bubbles keep
people in their own circles except for
vicious attacks and hate speech and
insults so that people do nothing
instead of be active so they watch
Netflix instead of be politically active
the oleg arcs and the billionaire class
get their way because others are bailing
out that's why I say we're at a
disadvantage we want to do things and
they want to keep things the same we
want to do things they want no-one to
get involved so that they can basically
maintain the status quo while
perpetuating the inequality cycles that
we've been seeing
by creating gridlock and despair and
apathy they win so we have to overcome
that and we have to do stuff and this is
one of the ways one of the ways in which
the Trump era will have destructive
effects well beyond his presidency
however long it ends up lasting earlier
we dealt with some of the other ways
that Donald Trump is going to have a
destructive effect on the United States
well beyond his presidency this is one
of those ways and it is that trolling
and all sorts of other horrible stuff
are actually considered political
discourse and a way to discuss political
issues and figure out who we want to
vote for that is extraordinarily
destructive and one of the great
insulators against this if there are
many but one of the great insulators
against this is a more educated
population a population who under
Stan's critical thinking and
epistemology as we talked about
yesterday in that segment interviewing a
group of uneducated white swing state
female voters go back and check that one
out if you missed it